i'ma eat at the Chicago Way this is
corny by the way I got in a little bit
today we eat in New York pizzas vs. cake
I feel like New York Pizza is the best
piece of course I even better than the
Italians I think so
Italians are gonna be mad but yeah cuz
they eat with a fork and knife we eat
with our hands son you know I mean we
fold the pizza you know what I'm talking
about I also like this also
misconception when New York Pete's are
not people be like this place has the
best New Year pizza no New York Pizza is
New York Pizza you could get a great
pizza anywhere in New York City
everybody knows that New York water is
the secret sauce to the pizza and New
Yorkers will back me up as a matter of
fact there's places like in Boston and
in California that import the water just
to make pizza
this is Pizza versus cake all right
that's like a parmesan cake
I spoke to an Italian and then I was
like I would say about New York Pizza
she was like I don't know how New York
think they had the best pizza and I was
like wait about Chicago and she was like
they're even worse
[Laughter]
my name is Liz grew up in the suburbs of
Chicago and I grew up eating Chicago
deep-dish style pizza you know any time
we would have events or outings they
would bring like thin crust and
deep-dish pizza and whenever anyone
would try the deep-dish who wasn't from
Chicago their mind was always blown by
how good it was and it was always the
first one gone unlike New York there are
certain places that have the best
deep-dish pizza that's deep-dish pizza
is at Lula Mattie's so you gotta go to
specific place they get good pizza in
Chicago got it I do need to apologize to
you that you say you grew up eating
deep-dish pizza I'm sorry oh right I
don't think so I've never tried to add a
vagina you know I'm gonna try it with an
open mind I was been to New York and
I've had
like literally all the variations of
thin crust pizza and it's great don't
get me wrong but like it's like a paper
towel version since I'm eating it in New
York style I will use my hands
you need a fold deep stupidest way to
eat piece I've ever seen in my entire
life
it's better than eating with a fork I
tell you yeah this is perfect so when
you undergo you could just eat pizza on
the train if you have to or walk down
the street yeah or you could take the
time to enjoy it properly as you should
when it's good quality Pizza New Yorkers
don't got time for that
oh it's just kind of like it's kind of
like a sucky paper towel why do you have
to fold it like what is it that you're
hiding you know what I mean like I'll
hold it up better is easy how much you
don't get better and then I bet you
don't get your hands greasy like this
I'm saying
it's not bad pizzas pizza pizza is good
if you're looking for more of like a
light snack it's like on the go share
alike get your paper towel you know but
if you want to actually have like a good
meal and sit down and like enjoy it deep
dish oh my god this is your first time
trying it yeah you're like a casserole
I'm gonna try it out with open mind you
know it's all yes i'ma eat at the
Chicago Way this is corny by the way
let's see this is a lot of cheese in you
exactly not bad it doesn't taste like
New York feed that off tastes good
cheese casserole I can consider there's
a pizza it's not back I'll be honest
with you it is delicious it doesn't
taste like a pizza found in today why
does it taste like a pizza I don't know
like me because I'm used to a pizza
being a certain taste it really taste
the tomato sauce very cheesy this is it
has a lot of cheese very cheesy just
tastes more like a looks like Parmesan
cheese I guess I like how it has a lot
of cheese cheese cheese is what makes a
piece of pizza so yeah
wanna have more of it so that they don't
do it you guys don't do it with the
tomato sauce in between the cheese in
the and the dough which is crazy too
that's what I feel like it's missing
it's a NATO sauce is there any tomato
sauce probably mixed in with a cheese a
little bit on the top there turns on the
plates you go yeah my favorite place has
it on the top on the top oh you have a
similar sauce on the top I think that's
a little bit more sickest because then
the cheese tends to slide off this way
the cheese is baked it cooks into the
bread and then you get the sauce on top
so you're gonna get all three flavors
without it totally coming apart it's
delicious I like it I like about goes to
Chicago
I'm gonna eat a Chicago pizza but like
this is how you gotta eat a Chicago
pizza you gotta take another way that
it's pizza or anything tonight just see
it as a cake is it better than New York
I don't think so to be fair I also
create new york pizza is delicious
i think pizza is so good because of what
it is bread the cheese sauce so why not
make a pizza that is more as a New York
or we see pizza something like to get on
the go
I feel like it's a street food I feel
like this is more like I go to a place
I'd rather sit down and eat like a
chicago-style pizza yeah you couldn't
eat that on the girl don't take me wrong
Chicago pizzas good
Oh already it has like twice the amount
of cheese on it I know it's gonna be
that much more flavorful it's not floppy
look that that is sturdy that holds up
like it should so you're trying to
figure that out already - like three
bites I agree I think this one like
doesn't have a ton of sauce on it cuz
it's like la style pizza I see your
point there yeah is a little flimsy
they're both delicious but it's hard for
me to wrap my head around cause it's
just what I hear a lot of from New
Yorkers is that it doesn't feel like
pizza it doesn't look like pizza you
know what I'm not hearing anything about
is the way it tastes okay that's all I'm
saying
so you saying you don't like deep-dish
because it doesn't fit your concept of
what pizza is yes and it's missing
tomato sauce B this tastes more parmesan
ish much easy more cheese it tastes
cheesy but it tastes more of a Parmesan
cheese
a sense Smita taste like cheese to me
without the parmesan if you want to add
a Parmesan cheese on your pizza that's
fine you know maybe you like that flavor
the secret get into New York pieces the
New York water sounds like much mumbo
jumbo to me water
Chicago it's the air okay I feel like
what you're saying is the flavor if the
cheese comes out more and you can't wrap
your head around the fact that it
actually does taste better because
there's a fit your concept of what a
pizza is this going to fit my concept of
what a piece a is New Yorkers were picky
like that when it comes to our pizza we
love our piece of street food you're on
the go is just like it's just perfect
it's like a dollar fifty two you get a
piece of get two slices in a soda for
how much that cost for a whole pie
probably like 40 bucks or something 40
bucks you don't really do if you go to a
good place you buy the whole thing you
know ultimately I think we both greeted
this style tastes superior you know if
you were to call that a pizza it does
taste it does taste a little better than
this one that's over you yes a few words
we'll call that a pizza I think I get
why New Yorkers hate deep fish so much
because it doesn't fit their notion over
the way a pizza is yeah if you're not
doing something the way in New York or
watch it to be done then it can't be
done that way I think that you know
perhaps people should open their lines
what a pizza can be and what it can
accomplish there's other names for that
already than what I got trying to put
that in the pizza category and there's
something kinases that can fit in let it
go somewhere else where it needs to be
you know what that's fine you can have a
put pepperoni on that oh my god more
deep dish for me today taste wise that
it what it will win always what is this
taste wise deep dish is the superior
pizza first of all how you gave us cold
as pizza is an injustice of both with
one of the pizza in the castle world
this is an insult to New York Pizza
because we don't eat this way for sy all
right you gotta eat this do with your
hands son we're were your hands that's
pizza yeah okay keep complaining give me
the trophy trophy thank you on it we
don't want it we don't want it
[Music]